yippee k we were lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm revealing
10 characters pics are cut from
Incredibles - who you might wish had
been included in the movie if you're
joining me for the first time be sure to
tap the bell to get my new videos and
also leave a comment about the movie for
a chance to win an awesome Funko pop
spoilers ahead so take care if you've
not seen the film or add this video to
your watch later playlist although we
never saw her and only briefly heard her
voice frozen's wife honey was a huge hit
with fans in the first movie so much so
that Pixar used her only moment in the
sequel to promote the film in the
trailer sadly that's about as much as
fans got of honey and Incredibles - but
we could have had more as she very
nearly made it on screen the filmmakers
said they not only created a designer
for honey but they also initially
included her in the movies opening
sequence
unfortunately the scene was scrapped as
writer director Brad Bird felt it didn't
fit and the movie was already too packed
so once again we only got to hear
honey's voice in the sequel which bird
believes it's funnier it's a real shame
that honey didn't get to make her
on-screen debut as I know many Pixar
fans were hoping she'd make an
appearance the storyboard of Hanna's
deleted cameo will be on the blu-ray and
her design was reused in the movie for
one of the many supers assembled on the
yacht at the end look for the character
with pink hair blueish colored suit and
long gloves plus goggles when Edna mode
discovers that elastic girls new super
suit was created by designer called
Alexander girl Becky she's absolutely
furious last across the first thought is
back out back now girl Becky only gets a
name check in the final film but
originally Edna's rival super suit
designer was actually going to appear on
screen in a suit fitting scene with
Elastigirl gal Becky's character was
meant to deliberately contrast with Edna
as his designs were all about showing
off and drawing attention to him as a
designer rather than focusing on the
needs of the supers he's designing for
and as if that wasn't enough to get
Edna's blood boiling his designs even
broke her Golden Rule nuggets giving
Elastigirl a cape she clearly didn't
like or need and some early designs of
Helen riding the elasticized show her
wearing a cape at the same time wearing
capes while closed
right ugly fast spinning objects is
clearly something that's very dangerous
as we saw in the first movie a character
that many fans would have liked to have
seen returned for the sequel was Carrie
the babysitter Carrie's role from the
first movie was expanded when she
featured in the short film Jack Jack
Attack which showed her discovering baby
par superpowers and then having her
memory wiped by Rick dicker and the
filmmakers appear to have had a brief
cameo in mind for her in the sequel as
concept art of Carrie and her parents
appears in the art of Incredibles to
hardback book in an earlier version of
the movie Winstone Dever didn't have a
sister instead he had a brother called
Nelson who was the original villain as
the story progressed though Brad Bird
decided the villain would actually work
better as a female character so the
decision was made to scrap Winston's
brother and instead introduced a sister
called Evelyn and as a bonus the team
found they were able to make the
relationship between Evelyn and Helen
stronger and more interesting than they
were with Nelson and Elastigirl Nelson's
design wasn't totally lost though and he
was reused as the wannabe super heel
actrix and before he'll actrix there was
originally a female version of this
Lightning powered super called she
electric she electrics design ended up
being used for Evelyn who as I mentioned
was made the main villain for the movie
while we do get lots of new
super-powered characters in the movie
even more supers were designed for the
film but didn't make the final cut for
example Brad Bird mentioned a character
called over think he was originally
going to be a bigger part of the film
but ended up only appearing very briefly
with the International supers at the end
of the movie and who was never named
according to bird his power was
incredible mental energy but he takes
his time to consider every single thing
and usually misses his opportunity to
correct whatever the problem was because
there's always one more angle to explore
the whole idea of an overthinking
superpower seems a bit strange as it
sounds less of a superpower and more of
a chronic weakness I can't see the
humorous potential but it sounds like
the character might have been a bit too
complicated to get across on screen
another secondary superhero that appears
in the outtake section of the art of The
Incredibles 2 book is cosmos Asst
judging from his name and the many
celestial designs considered for his
super suit I'd say he was probably going
to have various powers of cosmic
manipulation cosmic powers can endow
users with powerful abilities such as
manipulating matter across space and
time and creating force fields or
portals between locations and dimensions
cosmoses could have been on a par with
extremely powerful superheroes like
Captain Marvel and Jean Grey's Phoenix
force if cosmoses was only meant to be a
secondary superhero or a wannabe super
like void and her crew then I think he
was probably cut from the movie because
he might have been too formidable an
opponent for the Incredibles family and
even possibly the extremely overpowered
Jack Jack the filmmakers had yet more
ideas for supers they hope to introduce
in the sequel there was berserk Lee who
reminds me a bit of Batman villain
poison ivy with the green mask and leaf
light cake behind her and her name
suggests she might have had some wild or
out-of-control powers shock and or a
pair of supers and their name and her
style suggests they have some kind of
electrical or Lightning powers the
purplish colors in their hair and
glasses made me think of the Wonder
Twins from Superfriends however they
don't share similar powers with that DC
duo the deleted trio Mega Man and Co
seem to be the least developed of the
supers design wise and look like they're
wearing home made costumes so it's
possible they were going to be used more
for comic effect than any real threat to
the Incredibles now do you wish any of
these characters had appeared in the
movie be sure to comment and subscribe
for a chance to win a cool Incredibles
Funko pop tapleft to check out 10
awesome deleted scenes from the movie
and tap right for my full pixar playlist
including easter eggs and all Jack
Jack's powers explained remember to tap
the bell to get all my new videos as
soon as I upload them and if you enjoyed
this video a thumbs up is always
appreciated thanks for watching and see
you next time
epic a movie lovers